a cat came for a game hello guys hello
everyone welcome to the stream I look
you look terrible alright winter Gotham
you guys should like ya request to play
us on chess calm we're playing on there
today instead of yay so if you got a
chest calm account and gets place yeah
log in to your account on chess calm and
send us a challenge we're not going to
jab anyone on no chat no chats
how are we playing this place about it
okay let's play this yeah but it's a it
says an arrow or cured so yeah it says
okay
all up
oh oh now now I can see yeah
but it shows an ad so haha yeah okay
let's skip the ad don't skip the ad guys
okay yeah we lose money no you can't
challenge us a 120 minute game so you
have to be on the shorter time control
yeah let's make it blitz
thank you and how are you hello everyone
Thank You vidonne he says we all look so
cute let me fix my hair the wind is real
outside so yeah let me let me so we are
playing Kali Charan again again yeah he
just played Jessie and resigned so oh he
wants revenge but I don't think he will
get revenge today so Argentina love you
thank you hey team hello xeroxing how
are you I hope to you are doing
fantastic today oh do we have a link to
for them to challenge I think I come on
Chester we can create a link on chess
calm just just hold on a second we'll
share it link yet how do you say that
name there are four there axis I just
maybe wing that answer I'm not sure if
it's ha hello so far welcome david says
your hair is fine thank you David
you're too kind it will be giving you
the link momentarily
my hairdresser was the mother nature
today so
haha we've got little queenside castle
hello Hector
Oh his real name is Hector not Linux's
it's just alias will share the link for
the challenge don't worry guys alias
Iran I love you we have someone from
Iran you want to hello to Iran please
play me challenge us on chess calm this
is making me nervous
I mean we have the night defending on a
2 but maybe hello team hello and a L
Genie Gary we will play you if you send
us a request on Chester calm Hey Aditya
I did you Eddie yeah
goodbye my love Kalicharan
goodbye design there's a link there's a
link if you want to challenge a moment
of silence for the fallen warrior hi oh
yeah there you have it the link is in
the chat so you can use the links to
challenge us on chess calm the username
is st. Louis chess club you can see it
on the screen on the bottom of the
screen it says that they can't challenge
while we're playing okay um interesting
yeah very interesting I think I think
you can know I do that and they can yeah
there must be a setting hmm you are 11
years old
how nice scary I wish I played chess
when I was 11
me too well you are the lucky ones wish
I had started okay when did you guys all
start playing chess I started playing in
January yeah really yeah like I've been
in the chess world for a very long time
like about four years but I haven't
started like I didn't start until
January because like I was too shy yeah
my approach to chess world was rather
unconventional it's just like normally
people play and then get to meet people
and first I meet I met people and then I
started playing chess like it is the
other way around yeah that was kind of
yeah I like your high life by the way
[Laughter]
yeah I could say that it's nice like per
Felicia
sorry guys I'm being a lady distracted
by the amazing highlight alison has
hello I'm Rick all right I suppose
people have to wait so we're done
challenging oh I'm sure there is a
setting for that
I don't really mix months ago
were in October so we started in April
oh nice yeah but yeah there must be a
setting for that I'm sure because people
could challenge me when I'm playing on
chess calm oh you play on just yeah I do
that's why I ran out of rating you
started to play 15 years ago and you're
still novice it's fine it's not normal
for cannabis yeah yeah I wonder how good
I would be where dc-6 to others from c4
how they get my Knight to c4 c4 c5 and
b7 know these things that is some weird
stuff so those I mean yeah you can
challenge us but we'll figure that out
there must be a setting some weird stuff
so yeah because
one of them says yeah I'm curious to see
what door so like where you're going
with this so currently birthday is
playing on st. Louis chess club's
official account so you can see it on
the screen okay so apparently there's a
setting yeah there is a setting yeah I
lay multiple games at a time yeah no no
no they can challenge you and you can
accept yeah it's not like random why
don't we lead us yeah what we usually do
but we're on chest comm right now just
because Jesse was using that before the
stream so we stuck with it yeah
and it's an amazing website is it open
for anyone to challenge I believe so
yeah Damon Matt says does I am dorsa
have a GM norm do you have a GM norm no
not yet that's cute yeah I'm posting
it's okay I don't lose on time ah some
muling day we'll fix the setting after
this game I mean really has nowhere to
go
Oh your username is a in Turkish and he
says the middle one is cute are we not
cute no just kidding just kidding
wait what just happened so that you
couldn't get the clean sacrifice
[Music]
resign there should be a midsummer okay
let's let's take a moment is it yeah or
I thought you would put the Queen there
I was there and then if you put the
knight on geese ha ha ha ha it's very
close I can feel it and goes to and then
okay they're running low on oh oh well
ha ha we're doing G so much better
woo there we go wait oh ok cos he can
still he can still okay all right yeah
can you do the setting Oh Jess kazoo
he's one of my fellow followers ah hi so
you can you there we go
here yeah and play and multiple yeah
yeah here this one yeah now save it and
they there you have it you can challenge
us now use the link I'll share the link
oopsies you wanna play come on chase
could you share the link again please
thank you
there you have it the link is in the
chat you can challenge Tracy all right
we've got Tracy's to that you go to play
and there might be yeah they're a bunch
of wait what are you right here where it
says that is that no yeah this is just a
notification you can challenge like
accept challenges over here good thing
someone knows how to use chest colds all
the time out
playing Jesse earlier maybe we should
play someone else kiss goose is my is my
follower so you could play new yeah
strong one I don't believe you I don't
blame you Gigi just just do it three
[Music]
okay okay you accept it alright this
looks good so far
Danny stop laughing back there yeah yeah
I meet me too like it's just like an
internal I guess somebody's that I got
this notification on my phone clicked it
realize they were watching Elijah I hope
I thought I'm watching an uploaded video
but ten minutes later I realized to the
livestream welcome hello eclipse it's
it's good not taken hello Anna thank you
for your nice comment
meet the one and the right one and the
left one cute there you have it yet your
daily dose of fluttering too many
beauties on one screen soon I know play
the Queen how about um c4 no that's F 4
F F 4 I know it's not a good one okay
I'm sorry I can't see I need to I need
to be closer to my screen what what is
you took the night
oh yeah it's a check yeah yeah you can
maybe they either need to block it with
something or I play the King no no
justjust just take the night I mean come
on yeah no yeah that doesn't look too
good so we should walk that Casca's
behave my ladies are not used to this
kind of thing
treatment oh no you can't challenge now
you should use the link in the chat
scroll up yeah there you have it you
have the link
able take oh yeah all right what's the
plan yeah exactly
with the Vedant hey it's like our chap
is not gonna say anything focusing on
the game we play here yes getting closer
do something with that night
like you should take with the pawn on it
good for you Gary congratulations
Artie I'm sorry Tracy it sucks and I'm
sorry too for you then how many people
are working in the trailers Chess Club
do you know the number of people who are
working at the Chess Club there is no no
I don't know yeah many people are
putting their love like precious time
and effort to make this club amazing so
we love them all mister we could like
run him down no we can't I mean we could
wait what he's going to take our work
why didn't we take actually that is boom
okay this is looking better
[Music]
yeah this is totally Tracy style I can I
can feel it
you managed to make it your style oh no
Gary you can you can use the link to
challenge us it's in the chat all right
well at least he didn't checkmate us at
least human buddy is he an i oh yeah
he's a quite strong player he wins all
my tournament self-congratulations
Tesco's good one I'm still saying the
old thing so I can't even focus on the
game because like this is delayed of it
yeah there is a slight delay so I yeah
yeah but this is the real-time screen I
suppose go to play yeah and there you
have the list you can select any one you
can oh we have quite a few people we
just played back and then solitaire bat
was just just played Jesse so should not
doors is also similar yeah thorns also
might fall over so you can they want to
do connect a website yeah mato Yama
interesting username yeah mato from its
heli all right
okay
what opening are we ready I guess isn't
it four nights if you bring your other
night Oh
we prefer unrated games if possible we
do I mean I don't think that we have a
preference yeah but on rated-r why okay
anything goes you guys you can tell each
other what happened are you reading the
same cop yeah I get I guess so that's
why what we're not even gonna yeah we're
not bothering with silly comments yeah
yeah I'm sorry Internet is an open space
where people can pour down their toxic
comments so don't be toxic be a nice
person okay yeah we actually prefer
rated games give us your point we want
your rating you guys for Knights is an
EP for opening yeah we figured that out
Daniel thank you for letting us know
well I didn't know that but you guys did
it not me so I think it's fine I mean
there are a bunch of openings and they
give give them plenty of names yeah
it's confusing it's fine what's your
favorite opening my favorite black
Berlin and white scotch scotch is good
the opening its middle one single I mean
come on this is the chest dream not a
dating website yeah you can you can go
to match.com I don't know Mom both in
there whatever just advice from a coach
thank you we want your draping - ha ha
you're not going to be careful with
those words you're next
Trevor you should challenge
could you please one more one more time
tell your names not sure which one is
which one sorry
this is doorstop who is currently
playing and taken to challenges this is
Alison hello and this is Nikki hinder
what is your favorite opening the Berlin
why is your favorite opening the Berlin
because I think that it's the solid one
and I feel like I don't know the Berlin
oh it's like one set after you for like
you do like two nights out and then
Bishop told ok it seems like it's a
solid one no rule opus yeah again
Spanish yeah instead of putting it
instead of I was like instead of doing
the
pawn to a6 you take your other knight to
f6 instead of pushing the darling
instead of playing this somebody saw my
name completely wrong on that chat they
spelled it Allison Allison Allison I
guess I was on line on the line then
good luck toys I think I think it's you
I can tell by your you challenge does
giant googa googa giant googa okay
interesting username what is the
webdiver what is the strongest opening
for a wipe what is the strongest opening
for wine
there's many I think the Italians pretty
solid I mean yeah it's not strong and
you know there's a funny thing there's a
funny thing if you turn on the engine it
shows that like one before it's actually
slightly I mean it's not winning
slightly with it but I'm not a default
player I used to do that one I mean it's
a good approach yeah yeah but okay look
like look like Kenny beat Nakamura in
much of 10 games of course yeah sure
Alice and I was stunned
thank you all right one a three is the
best opening first I can confirm that
one a three is so solid you shouldn't
play give your opponents a chance I
should be a comedian like alpha zero
place one c4 so it's the best yeah you
can you can take that route it's one of
the approaches moukhtar wants to know
who we think is the greatest of all time
what do you think there's so many I mean
right now I am pretty I am pretty biased
in this sense that it's a casparo like I
love them yeah I'm a big fan you guys
they gave us a little group named Nikki
Alison endorser yeah we have V
artificial long time who would win tall
or a cup of Lanka I don't know they
actually don't know too much about
either of those two players I'm still
kind of new to the tech world I just
joined in jade wardo I'm sorry
no how much money do you have
I'm too young for marriage
Aronian is bet is the best he's a monk
Aronian is very nice he's a top player
definitely a favorite for sure casparo
is the gold gold and ambassador for
chess could Einstein beat Marcus Carson
if you leave today no this is like come
on you guys like oh what happens if we
play chess on Mars and question question
Bruce Alec I of course all I guys in
what sense
like it's a is it down 64 squares or in
a fighting he wants them to take with
the night
thank you
no why'd the song goes in my mouth what
are you gonna take it with the bishop
how come you took with the rook I've got
some dolls leave today whatever you owe
my gosh it's so good to have like
multiple eyes like who's next
you are you are also doing great today
brilliant I can play but I don't want to
play someone what is the raping a girl
on the right I could play this person
which one is on little Canadian they
want to read it's norsu so so what if
you're anything current dating 20 to 80
something she said like quotation marks
2 to 8 something you're gonna bring
their Bishop I just I'll give you an
advice I'll give you an advice just go
on google and type Dorsett roshani
and it takes you to feed the page you
can see her rating over there who are
these women
well we are we this is Allison you and
Nikki I was about to do something wrong
let's do this nice to meet you young
fool now that that guy's defended just
move around okay do I want to do that
that'll their queen will just come
and I guess I'm just gonna do yeah they
pretty much they knew it I don't like
playing these three mini-games yeah I
prefer summer games should i doing a
pizza maybe I can okay they they're
asking your a thing I guess I don't have
usual rating cuz I haven't played in
enough tournaments okay I'm bleach s
right now my range is rating oh my god I
am ungrateful to what is it hello Alison
and Mickey
hello my glass milk Bosch L cuckoo hmm I
don't know how I don't think I'll make
you a thing is 404 not found oh my gosh
I need to bring my dark squared Bishop
out Tracy I love you Tracy you're the
only one who supports my joke do you
think yeah four would be mine I can't
believe all this beautiful girls Lily
save lives right now thank you
we have more ladies I don't have that
much time so I really shouldn't be
thinking about this too ah just just
move okay okay
yeah Allison seems to be a current
actress so how did you even talk about
that the check is getting weird
oh I know maybe do something like that
okay so are they going what are they
gonna do wait I don't think I liked what
I just did
yeah I and this Bishop needs to come out
because my rook is not defended a big
goof
dis yeah no yeah um
no yes
Chris Cole Hendricks says I found your
horrible joke at 200 success thank you
thank you
oh okay what a mistake
Oh magnificent gamer says webdriver
torso my NIC will upload our game to my
channel
oh no oh wait no that's right oh no it's
not I can't do this let me where are
they gonna go with that you know I have
one drop of focus and it goes when I'm
doing something else
one drop like wait oh my gosh yeah I'm
stupid
oh they didn't see it do this they could
have oh dear I think they could have
back recreated but they didn't see it so
that's good oh okay okay
what about oh oh no Damon met I mean
could be many I don't know who but it
could be Matt Damon said Alison future
DM hello Matt wait hi
huge mate in one I don't yeah you might
have a nice dream Thank You JJ Ellison
no I'm in no position to be trading how
about no oh wait oh hey no they're up
three so I shouldn't do that
yeah let's just see what they'll do
about this you can they're gonna they're
gonna take my queen
just take it big baby no no no no maybe
move the knife yeah well yeah I want to
kind of wanted my knight to be the
doodle cakes okay
I mean I see the previous position by
the way but I say move the night I see
the previous position oops sorry I'm
distracted again this bad I don't know
what you're running out of time
yeah oh my gosh are they gonna double up
their looks
probably yes actually I I can survive
this but I am so much I'm so down on
time oh my gosh no my knight has nowhere
to go
[Laughter]
we need dorsa to come back alright that
Knights a goner this is atrocious I
don't like this I'm just slow yeah one
second two seconds okay now to second Oh
best movie sign Nikki it's all your
fault it's not my fault what did I do
I'm just encouraging Alison here that
she could become a future gee I kind of
want to sneak in to start anywhere I
started going I distract myself I
distract everyone I'm to blame
is that okay you can run the analysis
actually and see your mistakes yeah yeah
it's a great tool if you are new to
Chestnut Cove yeah I don't usually shave
my star shameless and advertisement okay
so I did my little yeah you can actually
usually try and see retry your mistakes
like you know I have no click on yes and
yeah you can it shows me right yeah yeah
it doesn't show me like on the board
what I should do
yeah just click it does show you on the
board
but yeah I was it this like a terrible
mood like what is this saying it's
probably a blunder and I take e - that
was a blunder yeah I should have taken
with like my queen okay no you did
report
and it shows you what was that fifteen
no analysis on the second tab fifteen
move 15 well yeah yes miss here it says
you should have taken with the rope
instead so it's a double question mark
it's a blunder you should have taken
with your rook instead not your night I
wonder why that is
mm-hmm okay now I think my blank I can't
see over there okay okay let's let's go
back to challenging because this is what
the strand is about okay how do I get
back to that Nikki I'm not used to
Chester we don't have anything anyone
named Emily so I don't know who you're
talking about
: the G Kiki she oh okay okay
there we go yeah all right are you going
to play someone just go and play
yeah there you have it excuse you well
just a little scroll there might be
people down there Patrick you can you
can do yeah I don't like these three two
games it's a lot of pressure my blitz
baby yes life is I just realized my
blitz is like way lower if my followers
are here they will challenge me and book
and I don't want that Nikki do you want
to play Oh No yeah next one
Tracy's currently playing against who I
can't read the maja knee who is Emily I
I don't know who emily is but is that
Emily what is your Instagram we don't
have an Emily Emily not found Fargo 404
there are a lot of people challenging
yeah there there are quite a few people
in the line but you can also challenge
us and we'll see if you are the one
where are you from Emily we don't have
an Emily here you guys Hey ladies
hello then should we challenge for
longer time control Nikki Alison Tracy
that's it no Emily fear in the room okay
so I mean the the longest time control
should probably be like five minutes
because where is our that blitz she's
drinking her tea
taking a little tea break who's next who
are you Emily okay we don't have an
Emily here okay so I actually used to
play d4 and then night was that ff3 okay
I recently took that I should play d4
Bishop f4 is everyone on the screen from
us Allison give us your AC and I are
it's a good night
were you born here no okay I'm not born
here I wasn't born here
I'm foreigner I'm an alien I'm not
sharing my Instagram Tracey's known for
her great gifts
she likes gifting no no you do you guys
wanna you did that to me Emily is an
alpha zero sister so she doesn't have a
rating
I suck at the French desserts how you
play against the French defense so I
don't have any tips so I choose the
variant where you push a 5 but yeah
are you guys asking about Emily Trask Oh
could be although she used to run ladies
Oh Emily's not currently here play one
d4 okay I took over a bunch of women is
it not where did you born I was born in
Turkey I made up Emily don't have Emily
okay it's just the troll okay okay let's
focus on the game and yeah the current
position it's up there I'm just a
reminder for myself that night it's been
yeah but no big deal because it's
defended by the other one so we're good
what do you thinking are you thinking
about b3 yeah in this yeah yeah yeah and
in this in this kind of opening same you
have a chance to attack on the mm-hmm
and she's trying that I mean yeah the
best perfect present for a female chest
friend is a great gift no no no no no no
no no no no to Carnegie's idea yes of
course those doors supply Cecilia um I
don't know I've seen doors to do the
scotch
yeah the doors a big place card
Ellison like the Italian make it like
the Berlin's
door so place the Sicilian also
information Damon met what Oh II know be
paying attention who we are exposing our
repertoire online so people will prepare
against us not g5 someone's falling for
you excuse me don't fall anyway pick
yourself back up no fried liver when
your opponent is a vegetarian that's
rude I mean fried liver attack is rude
and disrespectful I'm saying to you
Tracy she did that to me I was in it I
did fall for it I always fall for it but
I'm I'm stronger it was like a
simulation of Hell Oh wasn't nice thank
you I'm so funny yeah I'm so funny I
should be a comedian just just vote me
welcome you
mm-hmm okay we we know what your
username is we will get around to
playing you hopefully yay what is your
favourite piece to checkmate with you
guys have any jokes preference change
any preferences piece to checkmate with
mm-hmm
I mean I often times find myself check
meeting with the Queen uh-huh
I like Poland checkmate those are
[ __ ] yeah
Bishop check mates are fun because use
both the bishops because people usually
underestimate pawns
and yeah you know they're they're going
to be lovely ladies in the future so
yeah you never know they have so much
potential yes they have so much
potential they could go on Hollywood and
become queens they can become anything
they want anything they want yeah a
little shopping night in an ideal world
when they are not blocked by other
people
somebody just asked what's your favorite
piece to be checkmated with um how about
no yeah next question
I'll take stalemate checkmate with the
king is back in bed I don't know what
you mean Damon uh
I don't pound check many windows GM's
except for officer I know every one
every one of them but I don't like that
you put the phrase like attracted to and
what kind of attraction is that that's
questionable you should question
yourself should question yourself
good move Daniel said it's a good move
Tracey yeah Tracey's full of focus she's
there
oh my gosh she's running out of stuff ha
ha I feel intimidated by your article
months about pieces to checkmate with I
mean anything goes you really I don't
have a preference just give me a
checkmate
palms are great so much potentially yeah
your ladies are funny and entertaining
Thank You Felix
I love your picture it's a cat Felix the
Cat maybe does Maurice as actually comes
around it does he does commentary for
the st. Louis chess club okay it's fine
it's a great gift if dorsa I am or W I
am it's he cheese and I am international
master title given by Fidel the World
Chess Federation
[Music]
how many members do we have there I
would really like to play Tracy it's
soul eater bat wants to play you okay I
mean but solitaire bat just got to play
Jesse I mean it seems like you are not
attracted to me excuse me you just have
a picture and it's like a default
picture provided by Google it's green
like how can I possibly attract it to
you like how in what world and plus I'm
taking so it's not even a question
hello hello hello Julian
hello are are are are check yeah no no
what happened here no no no it's fine
it's fine
yeah work we're good when I say it's
fine oh yeah it's coming
yeah hey GG that was a good game right
where's dorsa it's her turn unless you
let someone else plate wants to play
with you
Tracy oh it's so little if you like I
don't want to drop the leather so and
it's five-minute racy flagging chance
taking guys come on we are going out Oh
Gary's been waiting for half an hour oh
there's sorry Gary I knew we have a lot
of people are asking to play us though
and their giant who is your favorite
chess player
Magnus Carlsen or Fabiano Khurana I mean
both of them are they're both really
good excellent so I'm not here to judge
anyone I'll take both I mean not in that
sense I mean I mean one is number one
and one number two and come on
well I'd like for that to switch up so
they're legendary selves judges good
games chess ago my French news title
what it's like a wish description
there's a website called wish they sound
like people like things on for like $1
and they have their description probably
translated or like
yeah the comment looks like it's a it's
taken out of like like a rich wish
description ah like random words oh it
was me who spoke Turkish yeah you didn't
you heard it just right your favorite
chess player is Joseph Henry Blackburn
it's a quite a trend to like him I
assume you like sacrifices he's known
for his sacrificial gameplay but the
thing is like almost every player in his
era played like sacrificial games and
one of the games actually the immortal
game one of the best games in the entire
history it's just like a full of
sacrifices in order to like get to trick
me yeah
the notion back in the day was if
someone sacrifices the opponent has to
accept it like today we have the option
to not accept it like I don't I'm not
going to take your sacrifice but back in
the day it wasn't I believe like it was
frowned upon maybe I'm not sure as far
as I read yeah it says right here yeah i
wasnt generally do outside of saying as
close and just oh well this stream is
all about chess so you're only answering
two questions let's hear an eel oh do we
have I don't have traces do you have no
we are currently underrated playing in
tournaments is scary guy yeah it's scary
I had my simulation in a tournament
thank you they shake it I did him thank
you what an awful question what is like
what what's your least favorite chess
player that's disgusting
how disrespectful
yeah where can you learn how to play
chess
oh that's a bad joke well you can't go
on our YouTube channel we have plenty of
videos going over openings yeah and
games all sorts of stuff you can learn
on the st. lous Chess Club
YouTube channel you can learn on li
chess I think I'm going on chess dock I
have that same thing like where you can
practice like we happen once and stuff
like that yeah they have an excellent
tactics tactics trainers you can do
rated puzzles and you can do underrated
puzzles and you can choose actually the
certain level that you want to practice
that day and it shows all the statistics
next to you and you can actually
practice the puzzles that you failed and
like the you can fact basically practice
the same thing over and over or like
same pattern different puzzle like it's
an amazing tool so I use it on a daily
basis I I do more puzzles than playing
chess which is probably harmful for you
the scariness of tournaments is the part
of the fun yeah I mean it's an
adrenaline rush yeah am i watching an
advertisement ad this is shameless
advertisement hashtag sponsor me sponsor
me I mean if you mean yes both of me
okay I'm sorry dude skirt skirt how can
i play with you after you finish good
there is a link let me copy that it's so
like your personal chess account
oh my personal translator I don't know
if they mean is that what they mean know
if you want to play online right now
right here there is a later like after
after the string I mean I have an
account but I usually don't play against
people who are not my level because
first it's heartbreaking when you lose
even if that someone is I mean you just
not ready to play someone that's like
that's not the link can I have the link
again thank you you smell good yeah a
bunch of eggs advertisement yeah I don't
know who that is
I know who that is but I simply can't
follow everything because I'm too busy
he's a he has a YouTube channel where he
analyzes games and I think he's from
Croatia Croatia everyone's a little bit
peculiar Raymond
yeah he's one of the one of the best
yeah
mmm that's disturbing enough elegant man
in the world
all right I want to play elegant chest
Tracie's so focus yeah this is how
exactly she behaves to me when we play
chess
you're gonna Castle it's just normal
Tracy
that's the Fisher code you take the
issue with no one for Best Buy test is
the Fisher code I like that's my excuses
carry on playing money for looking scary
the game I mean just games can be scary
well what a joke cheap car insurance
what a joke
I didn't
how did you guys end up at st. Louis
chess club well I just saw that they
were hiring so I applied finally finally
someone typed your name correctly great
move
oh you were in Iceland I want to go to
like the fact that we're losing the same
thing yeah it's so good and his grave is
I say thank you yeah you can go see him
in his grave yeah I think they turned
his house yeah there's a radio big open
I think it's a strong one do you prefer
online chess I mean I'm more used to
online chess sadly I won't play oh you
did I'm not getting paid but I'm open
for payments I'll insert my people down
below you can send me money
I love rejected I just play for fun oh
we like it oh so Gary and what was your
username Oh a giant goo giant yes mmm
interesting username I don't see him on
here we don't see you on here Gary
so Dimitri's I played my first
tournament this Saturday and it wasn't
very well but I liked the performance I
liked my performance
I just got Gary we can't find you using
Gary Taylor you want chess calm giant
conga goo got 200 toys we played that
game stories but yeah
lady bleep collie Chiron he played or
saw any play life coach I I I'm here for
coaching I've been squeezed yeah no no
they're like I said like it I'll insert
my people and it's Ivan is another way
to spend money oh okay
all this person has a weird-looking cat
as their default picture yeah he's one
of my fellow Birds
oh yeah he's from Sweden and even though
he doesn't speak Turkish he follows my
streams and start streaming
I started streaming quite recently I had
my personal account when in late April
but I haven't started streaming until
June maybe okay and then somebody said
how much T is doors are drinking a lot a
lot I wonder when she'll be done
drinking life I played my first rapid
tournament this Saturday what a going
through them how to that guy mine was
pretty rapid I would say but it was a
classical but is it ended rapidly Gary
we you have to send us a request to play
yeah challenges challenge us one more
time we couldn't find your challenge are
you sure I don't know you know how to
say their username but I thought they
were going to sleep who
Compton noise I don't know like
everyone's telling us their users like
okay so you go and check on I need your
stream lick its twitch.tv slash
and a why see I are nicer Niger slowdown
type it take a grab a piece of paper and
follow along
yeah you can use the link to challenge
five minutes is okay yeah yeah it's
perfect
don't worry it's my favorite I can count
to ten in Turkish nice sounds nice
how do you count to ten in Turkish do
you want me to count yes very cute start
Michelle Theotokos oh wow I mean come on
this is the chest tube not a language
stuff there's so many different like
people that come into the st. Louis
chess club every day yeah from all over
it it's so interesting to hear like all
the different languages I stream in
Turkish and English twice a week in
Turkish twice a week in English
Oh Daniel
but that's until six not not ten nicer
Dicer
nicer Dicer please just
it's a brand like knife environment oh
look who is down with her teeth I mean
not down with it
oh yeah man this area keeps changing
they're using now but it's all different
letters or numbers what languages you
know is that I'm at directed towards
Nicky it's me or other probably I speak
Turkish English and I know a little
Russian a little ancient Greek I can't
speak ancient Greek but I can read it
and let me see I studied German and
French like very basic level you know
French just a very basic level I haven't
I haven't used French for a long while
well okay giant Google yeah Tori's is
one of my fellow words
okay please Gary hi there you have it
Daniel congratulations I confirm she's
back yes door stays back yes I like
baguettes I can't fill it's fine
I understood like baguettes yeah I like
it
red color I mean it's not good for you
but it's good it's good it's good
thank you so much Gary you are nice too
yeah haha awesome
oh this is earth reverse Alekhine weapon
okay
what about bringing the pon de Raymond
no cuz the Queen's getting kind of stuck
who is your favorite world champion no
you don't like that who is your favorite
world champion dorsa capablanca Tracy
who is your favorite world champion
Jessie is okay
Ellison your favorite champion champion
I mean I really don't know I honestly
don't know don't know Tracy do you have
an answer or you are just focus okay
yeah she's focused I said I said casparo
before and I stand by my choice gone
Alec is gone yeah
oh sweet we get a rock I know or do we
not take that oh no this is the recent
one this is the old one oh I was
commenting on your game and I said like
play the play tonight yeah and it was
actually already played ah okay that's
all yeah this is the old like this is
lagging just little delayed I I don't
think it's lagging but it's a bit too
late for like obvious reasons and then I
wish they would bump that pawn down
which is the pawn that's on the F file
hmm cuz if we take then we could attack
their room oh no we can't that pesky
little night so just kidding
so I get a little a little late yeah
um okay so Doris I didn't like my pawn
idea
they want to take my bishop we need to
like yeah well we should open up that
diagonal something they also want to
take your Bishop is I like to eat
broccoli good for you healthy I learned
some child Turkish when I worked in
prison it is pretty cool
nice aditya you know where you can
challenge us don't got such silly
questions there is a link in the chat
right after your comment you can use the
link to challenge good to Navon this
looks beautiful
[Music]
you making you nervous why doesn't
everybody call me an elf maybe you are a
gorgeous creature that's why thank you
oh my god um thank you for following me
thank you
have you ever tried checkers I did when
I was younger
checkers I don't remember how to play
that yeah but you guys I just learned
how to play chess in January I had no
idea how to play I didn't know the names
of the pieces anything
ciao goodbye mats wait Chow Chows bye
right yeah sure it's like you can use it
happy
I know Norwegian Swedish English Dutch
and finished Dutch and German I tried
learning Finnish but after the numbers I
was gone like after 40 I said bye-bye to
finish it's a very difficult language Oh
Tracy's gone but I guess she was just
playing that how did you can't speak
those languages right of course I can't
speak every language in the entire
planet cute chess elf
Carla Tracy over here don't worry she's
no gm's
no GM's allowed I mean unless you want
to play Christian okay okay chess elf
thank you
I didn't know those existed how is not
always a good buy yeah good to know
shall I do that now so hello Oh
hello Bonjour Finnish is related to
Hungarian and Hungarian is one of the
most difficult languages to learn hello
Matt welcome you can challenge doorstop
I mean you are on the computer playing
right now man this is Gary guys we
really need you out yeah I don't think
we could see you know are you kidding
you can challenge you can challenge us
on chesco using st. Louis chess club
alternatively there is a link in the
chat with you so scroll up okay I mean I
said black horse it literally says doors
that place yeah excuse you I don't know
I thought maybe like its doors or not -
listen guys I will play you if it's five
minutes and if you are below I won't
play I'm also not used to playing or
chess calm but it's not too different
from your chess
doors ablaze the people oh yeah you you
can scroll okay we need to find that
Gary person so if you scroll down girls
school
haha no who is that what GM's a
Christian oh that's Christian
oh no oh I give away my minute it will
be show we're looking for okay Gary we
can't find your username so I'm Gary
yeah we can't find you know I know what
his username isn't it's like who's not
on you yeah oh there this day I asked
Richard okay we should play him no no
it's this one
yeah alright Gary get ready there you
have it
Tracy Henrik said sorry for the dirty
flag by the way he's a very nice person
she just shook her head no no she's not
forgiving
look see no no no dude I saw your daily
yeah I saw your previous comments oh no
what are we going to I have to
hello I'm alright let's let's crush gay
oh people are commenting on their to
play Alice I'm scared do you want to
play me my self-confidence is Gaza it's
like a bug this government like my
self-confidence is gone so I can't play
Christian we're not going to play I
[Laughter]
leave my mom's for dad like for bullet
because my mouse is so good I need to
practice for a strong woman player in
America who's this strong I just don't
know the answer to that question be
strong I mean it's a tough comment to
answer I mean and then I could imagine
parents cups okay how would you define
strength she's not oh I thought the
Karan's cup was only us
no no it's international that was
international okay oh you Christian give
us the odds I mean I don't what what
does that mean Christian I mean he'll
probably sacrifice up time or material
that's not fair yeah I don't want to
play if you're gonna be playing
handicaps oh no I mean like Christian Oh
Jennifer you warm the US Chess
Championship
you is yeah yeah she just won the US
women so she's you doing pretty good
yeah she's 32 seconds in one minute
I'm pretty sure Christian can crush us
in Dirty Sexy sure well I think do you
think there's checkmate incoming
probably not he'll probably have
everything coming let me let me check
have you already won versus a
grandmaster and a tournament what kind
of question what Christian said dorsa
has a great chance uh-huh
I guess let's go putting and working on
this weekend this is so horrible
hello mr. Spock how are you doing I
don't think this looks too bad but I'm
also not super experienced
see there's two bottoms like this yeah
if they take them you can put your
knight up there and then like who's not
gonna take its chest
popular in the US ready populace why
does it say that it's not a tournament
we're not in an arena
yeah my bit Oh should we just it's fine
if you go
did the game pause oh no we're still
going maybe it was in the rain so
previously I don't know
can i play yes you can you can use oh
but she has that you can use the the
link down below to challenge but they
want to play you and listen who the
bullet chess games livestream they want
to play me yeah I actually have to leave
soon these nice I'll be excuse the
stream all the cool kids snapchat in
tik-tok I guess I'm not cool cuz I don't
have either of those yeah I have a
secret snapchat that nobody follows or
not that's my sexist
well it's very silly yeah
well there's a chance I won't be playing
today there's a bullet chest right
that's the one don't understand you're
not gonna read oh my god I really have a
good yeah yeah this is don't worry about
it like they're a bunch of toxic people
we can't do without can I have your snap
it's not public I'm using it for fun not
to publish things
I'm using it for filters basically oh
you don't yep I got your stream or
anything
no not snapchat I have a discard where's
Eric Rosen probably in his house yeah I
think yeah I don't think he's in st.
Louis even right now oh my god I was
just watching one of his streams where I
came in
hmm so it's funny they asked
wait everybody asked us who our favorite
world champion was but nobody told us
who there is yes tell us who's your
favorite world champion well I didn't
say I spoke Italian so
I don't have a social lady I am left my
home in lipstick and I think what
happened we lost on time this is 10 min
a B he used an engine might be too tall
too long
oh my can't control a minute 10 minutes
and above wait what
okay we accidentally what we're
accidentally playing two people at once
and somebody has to pay a diss upward
yeah oh boy oh boy
there we go one more time
so we're accidentally playing a rapid
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah oh so we have marks you
weigh me Kyle town we have one more me
Kyle town and somebody said Mike comer
who fun kappa blanka no engine please
play me oh come on
Mongoose vs. 2019 you said no engine
okay Gary I don't know
abort abort five minutes okay yeah
Oh freezer I like that you mentioned we
found she's amazing
Casper Oh are Steinitz nice shine it is
the first world champion and Casper oh I
believe is the thirteenth don't ask me
why did I learn this I like reading
things online
Judit Polgar is my favorite because she
makes her male opponents bang their
hands on the elevator when they lose
I liked you did oh by the way kramnik
and Judit Polgar will be commenting on
all the books our way I can't wait I I
think he loved I think he did give up
there's just why you wanted to play him
in Bullitt got my eyes open for chess
when Magnus from my neighboring country
became the world champion no I'm reading
a comment so I'll think I'll go for him
I really don't much don't know much
about other champions so my base of
choices is really small it's good I'm
honest definitely has an effect on
Nordic countries as I heard I didn't see
it myself I didn't experience it because
I'm not from those regions but good for
you it should be it should be great
cosplay is actually world not even a pro
[Laughter]
what's a really much nope I mean only if
dorsa wants a rematch the guy you just
played
[Music]
so yeah I'm gonna have to leave in a few
minutes Tracy did you want to take my
seat the way drooling seems like oh how
about no
come on keep the chest nice and clean
you guys yeah I hate when they do this
oh my god this is all about it's okay
but I don't like it you were beaten by
chess hustlers game in 1990 it didn't
know such a thing existed I'm not going
to give any other question please don't
please don't what yeah yeah yeah I said
keep the chat clean and the chat cleaner
shut or a chess - I mean just doing
anybody out here using engines yeah yeah
so I've heard alert alert
Paul instructor didn't damaged I believe
noise like yeah make this work
yeah I believe endure so it's like like
a st. Nicholas
I have no idea I have no I'm American
I'm not American I don't know who any of
those we just warned you to keep the
chat clean and if you do it I'll be
appreciated who didn't yes but remember
guys this time we're not gonna
acknowledge the trolls unfortunately we
are unable to send you a rematch oh no I
can help my right guys I'm signing out
source for the stream Thank You Allison
it was fun though do you want the mic
I'll make you my see you want take my
spot hey bye guys
yeah
all right I'll see you guys next time
really cool of you Dorsett to play us do
mortals in the chat yeah
why would I get oh I can hold it for you
I'm a kind person no people are so sad
that Alison is gone
the gays are without rating we want your
rating so you can send us straight games
[Music]
we have detectives in the chat
polonaise photo check I'm just defending
them well holdy like that oh that's more
of it
my rating is 2700 can I play next yeah
donations will go
hello justic welcome how many hours have
been yeah oh we have half an hour okay
okay it's 5:00
USCF which means that I am hmm it's fine
anything can happen on in online chess
got a thirsty
2580 I played chess 25/8 good for you I
wish I had 25 hours a day and eight days
a week I would sleep
I am the best chess player in my house I
live alone
Oh once I've all with a single pawn and
a king it's possible to win with a
single pawn and a king there are end
games who is the best female coach I
don't know who is the best female coach
[Laughter]
I mean female as in I mean or training
females or as a gender female
I don't have a chance to play at the
time it's okay it's fine okay yeah any
challenges any new challenges is this
Christian still there no it would be fun
I mean it's fine to lose a gift GM come
on any usernames that challenge cast
anyone anyone I mean Susan Polgar is the
chess coach that's for sure I can
confirm yeah old rival says pink in the
profile picture or think I can't read
I'm blind please oh okay Cup of theorems
okay Oh suddenly we have so many
usernames and Jeff okay
how could be could be country I I told
them that I was going wife convinced
I can't see underst no I'm like what
time control to challenge 5 and below
not bullet five or three plus two ladies
remember this mm-hmm yeah I do
uh-huh no I didn't have a chance to play
real opposites black because everyone
seems to be playing one d4 as wife so I
can't DD doors always chose me then
change haha Trevor says don't you hate
when you keep accidentally making the
world champion accidental mates my
favorite come on come on
Wandy for Best Buy just won't be for
Best Buy just like just your hand does
not Best Buy test okay you're not a
cheater a we believe in you come on now
keep the cream how we challenged you you
can go on Ches calm and find us
same with Chess Club and challenges but
alternatively there is a link in the
chat you can click on that link and its
entirety will let you to challenge us
there you have it it's on the chat yeah
Gary please
good for you doctor Slayer he's rated
4000 delicious good for you Markovian
only told us 1.d4 there must be a reason
why people play one d4 I I respect them
respect some some people some heroes
don't wear a cape some respect and I'm
one of them I respect I saw it online
found it utterly funny and just dicks in
my mind and I don't know I'm a view
person like I don't say I'm normal hmm
sorry Danny Oh any suggestions for white
old rival I'm out of good moves
I think old rival is in the chat he's
it's asking for suggestions for white
people are so sad that Ellison left
thank you for setting up the challenge
we'll be streaming until I believe 6:30
so we still have 20 minutes 4,000 and
rating yeah
you know minus 6000 so I just respect
combining everything's in 13 huh yeah of
course if I can't fillet decent then I'm
surrounded by so many GM's it's their
fault not mine it's their fault like
it's a shame of them not to Mike ha ha
another thing we are with your lovely
voice I know I sound like a heavy sucker
I do not smile no wait
my time screen okay there are demands to
bring back the chest elf Ellison and and
chest elf Ellison know this for a second
but relax to tune in in December when we
start streaming again because we won't
be streaming till then yeah but if you
want to play me come back on Thursday in
December I have it's got me ready for
ladies night December you guys yeah hey
this is our last beam until December
come back on December to find us you I
mean maybe not maybe I'm not wanted
after this she's the entertainment yeah
I am so entertaining I want to entertain
my mind is not not my word
oh this is good allison is gone we're
gonna accept your countryman next thanks
oh okay so you're gonna play
what
oh thanks yeah of course but
this every day
there I believe there will be a
tournament during November so that's why
we are unable to stream during the month
of November that's why we are going to
be back on December or in December
whatever preposition you use tap on your
country excuse you
and not play anyone because I played the
whole tournament three rounds a day
don't ask me it was house you started in
half that's the question no I don't
accept any questions
by the way by the way guys I can't even
make a segue by the way guys if you like
the stream please give us a thumbs up
and that's how we know we should be back
or we should quit streaming so if you
want to see these girls and just elbows
Allison give us a like thumbs up down
below and comment do whatever that
increases the engagement in this video
so yeah do it
no I think it expires after some point
maybe yeah no not not that person yeah
uh-huh
someone from Turkey is my countrymen
he's my compatriot oh what a minute
oh no not again imagine if this one
minute one minute crazy heart sorry like
bombing a king in the center handsome
wow GG that's I believe that's called
self fools mate yeah I believe this is a
fool's way I wanna thank you thank you
mate thank you next mate oh this is fun
it was fast I don't know
Oh
they're so they're so entertained by
that game I thank you thank you for the
game by the way we forgot to thank you
oh we thank to you now like winning the
mate Thank You next
oh thank you so much eclipse was that
you you want to you wanted to make us
entertain we were entertained thank you
it was fun suit again sir I would never
ever dream of saying that mate on the
board
I just heard it in the legends you know
good old legends you see it you witness
it online fishy
no she's so good she wants to find the
best moves that's why she's so focused
Traci's focus fireworks on chessboard I
think we need an achievement for that
achievement a lot do they see the board
or C's here's the current position it's
fine I don't I don't know what I'm doing
even 90% of the time oh we were going to
do end games yeah yeah I didn't have it
the chance because as I said I was when
I pushed this is a safe assumption to
think that in tournament everybody play
d4 against you as white yes everybody
played d4 and I'm when I pushed a fort
they either responded with d5 or look or
like they did a six
who we have things going on in the
background
and what was the other one
I played the Scotch not deep tell me one
time yeah
it's quite good yeah Nicholas hmm
I beat Nicholas no oh I didn't he played
for nice with me excuse me
goddess Italian this So Solid love it we
have fans of Italian in the chat
a 4 is the most powerful move covered
some some some children are watching
this and they would they will think that
day 4 is the best move and they play a 4
in the next tournament game and they are
ruined for life yeah don't don't don't
do this
this is what I don't like something's
fishy here I can smell you can smell
go bye-bye no way Joshu
enforcing shoot by the way that thank
you mate was a joke I hope you are not
mad that I'm trolling it's fine we loved
it that was entertaining but don't do it
again
don't do it for your own sake Harry the
H bond is stronger than a four you have
to know when to push the Harry the H
bomb otherwise
fortunately Gary you won't get a rematch
because we are running out of time we
will soon wrap up the stream who wins
the Fisher random on in Oslo Norway I
believe who are the contestants Magnus
Carlsen Fabiano Khurana Wesley soul and
I am the pony Archie is there anyone
else like it's a quite different so
there's four people ya know it's the
semi-final
it's the semi-final I don't know it's
not coupling I I believe mecha is also
playing let me check let me check my
fact this might not be as current as I
wish they would say let me see the
contestants and I will let you know
about my opinion oh yeah
it's Magnus Fabiano and upon me achieve
is this so I was right so I don't know
it's a strong field and I love the way
Wednesday performed in the semi-finals
no quarter-finals I keep confusing these
two so but like all of them are very
good chess players so I don't know
Karlsson might be a favorite but I
didn't really see him play during the
elimination part last year I believe
they had an unofficial Fisher random
championship in Norway again I believe
Nakamura won that one
if my facts might not be true Google
that Google that there are articles on
chest outcome - so yeah hmm I shouldn't
rely on my memory in this session
when can we see this crew stream again
if you want to want us to stream again
please give us a thumbs up and let us
know in the comments down below and I
guess we will be back on this in
December on December in December
in December I'm sorry I'm not good with
prepositions my language doesn't have
any prepositions so
this connector
ooh but mark the spa's play his best not
forgetting to Castle life
[Music]
time I know know that they did it on the
chat oh maybe it's me hitting the
Bengals the dad man by and I'm always
waiting almost thank you everything I
it's too long I couldn't read it sorry
Raymond please
what Oh No Bethany what's happening our
our computer is is done is haunted
because you know the season is Halloween
so it's the haunted computer but when
you experience is actually we can see it
online I know I have one seconds remove
oh my god oh my god Gigi the hamster
died what is it is it down stair or
Ninja Turtle yeah I believe this is a
good place to end the stream thank you
guys for watching us Thank You door spa
and Tracy for accepting challenges today
and if you like this kind of stream
please let us know so that we know that
we you want to see us again so give us a
thumbs up let us in the comments
just give us show us some love and I
believe we'll be back on in December in
two separate see you guys and you don't
have a voice we wish dorsa and get well
soon
healthy return thank you guys for
watching we love you
see you next time bye
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club